hello everybody markiplier here bringing
you more SCP containment breach I'm
gonna be starting each episode from the
loading screen because I don't want to
be just sitting there in the game cuz
you know bad stuff could probably happen
to me if those is sitting during the
game oh oh uh uh uh Oh sentient object
does it mean sentient object now I'm
gonna read this I'm actually gonna read
this no special containment procedure
scp-372 is to be contained in a Cell
five by four by two lined with
reinforced Plexiglas embedded into each
of the four walls of this cell will be
one infrared motion detector in the
event of a containment breach an alert
will be sounded that all personnel
should watch for any brief flickering
movements in the corner of their eyes
and a report immediately if one is
sighted scp-372 is a creature of unknown
genus approximately 2 liter box medley 2
meters long
Oh ox ability to metres long from head
to tail and weighing approximately 45
kilograms it has a long thin body with
eight pairs of narrow limbs analysis has
shown that it's muscle fibres are
redirected allowing for extremely fast
and precise movements every part of the
body is abnormally flexible in the limbs
are coated with small fibers that cling
to almost any solid surface in place of
ears eyes or ears it has aa
follow that screw I'm not reading that
what was that
oh I'm just getting out of here I'm
screwed up uh uh you can pause the
reader if you want I just won't hear my
voice reading it okay
ah gasps you guess gas mask oh god oh no
oh no it got me I can't see anything
ah oh that's nothing okay I thought I
saw like Slenderman or something oh good
golly don't tell me there's something
from me okay one huh nope as if yous not
behind me oh go away go go
he's still there
lifting dong hai what do I do now
ah I may have screwed myself cuz he's
right there and I got it I just got it
go until I hear it I'm so boned
Oh everything I do is wrong ah fudge
nuggets oh he's right there I'm so but I
don't know how to get away from them I
don't know he like got behind me or
something I don't know what happened
there does it okay
what is this nothing what's going on in
here why is it so dark
why is it so dark oh no I'm going back
now hopefully you went away ah what I
don't know yeah Oh God
Oh did the door god I hate it so much do
I can kill a CP in this thing I won 7-3
is his name please don't be there haha
finally she went away okay take off the
gas master okay I don't know where to go
now I'm kinda round I don't remember
which place I've been
Oh
wait a minute this is where I started
no way this is oh my oh my it is oh my
oh my is there any reason that I should
be here any at all I don't think so ah
okay I know that oh he's gonna pop about
nowhere I know I don't know it I know it
I know it I know I know he's just gonna
pop about nowhere okay this is one I
can't get in because I don't have the
key code
oh no I haven't been able to go anywhere
I think I'm just going in circles now
cuz I don't have keycode passes I don't
have to keep pass codes I just have
documents this one too I think I don't
know I don't know there might have been
like an error in the C for this map
this is like something like how to get I
know there's like some officers I've
seen before well I'm not sure now ah
come on I wasn't that close I'm not sure
anymore
cuz I was in that I was in the other SCP
strummin unless it was like a key pass
somewhere I didn't see it
oh I don't like this game I don't I like
this game
I do not like help this wrong it's wrong
wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong so wrong
it's wrong everything about this is
wrong it's wrong wrong it's wrong I'm
wrong you're wrong we're all wrong
all right for being wrong okay there we
go
okay maybe there's something in the
darkness that I'm missing oh no oh no oh
no close the damn door ah god I gotta
stop doing that that's where I don't get
that close I'm so bad at this game
Oh give me going me heart palpitations
please don't be there SCP oh not again
not again again again and again back up
back up back up
no come down no no no taking this off
oh you're right outside that door hi
buddy I swear I'd press the back button
like just a bitty bitty bitty bitty
bitty bitty bitty bitty anybody anybody
many many many many baby I'm never gonna
reach the end of the game never reach
the end he's right in there I know he is
who is that
huh what was had suddenly he was coming
behind me you went away oh it sounds
like he's moving around in the walls
around me I swear oh no I know there's
something in here
what was that I freaking hear you
there's got to be like a keycard or
something here or something or something
or something or something or something
or something or something on the floor
maybe is that I don't know oh no I think
I might have to start a new game
something is not cooperating and there's
definitely nothing here right this is
definitely nothing
okay huh
I I don't think there's anything that I
can do now I think I have to I might
have to start a new game I'm not sure
I'm not sure I don't know oh I hate this
so much
oh it's okay I wasn't very far or
anything so it didn't matter that
everything was locked off cordoned off
ah
text messages how about that I don't see
him in there but she can change the
heartbeat here we go
look first let's go you in here are you
in here are you in here are you in here
Yulin aircraft I've got backup alright
alright I'll take you down with me
what more sure what we're trying
okay gas masks on what the hell what the
hell I can't okay start lagging like
real bad there I don't know what's going
on here we go do it screw you what
they're going on hey give the word I
can't do anything ah ha ha okay that's
all the time I got for this episode so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye-bye